i think people don't realize that  businesses like sports for example tom  brady it's not about anything other than  the [ __ ] game but then the game's  over and what does he do he goes out of  his way to go up to sac wilson says you  played a nice game like you can clap it  up you can talk to your homies about  like charity events and how's your wife  in business we don't realize that you  can try to beat everybody i want to be  better than anything you ever do  anything that you three ever do i want  everything that i do to be better but it  doesn't mean that your winning comes at  my expense nor does it not mean that i  can't give you roses when you're [ __ ]  dominating and in business world people  don't treat it that way